wir müssen leider draußen bleiben was
sonst nur hunde vor fleischereien
erdulden müssen erfährt gerade das
gleiten team in washington
es wird von der tramp administration von
den amtsstuben der hauptstadt
ferngehalten
obwohl es eigentlich keine amerikanische
art wäre dem nachfolgenden übernahme der
amtsgeschäfte so leicht und so effizient
wie möglich zu machen
donald trump sie das bekanntlich etwas
anders er hat trump vor dem ende welchen
kurs nimmt schon beiden jetzt in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste zunächst hier im studio
professorin christiane lemke ist bei uns
politikwissenschaftlerin an der leibniz
universität hannover wachte
tausendfreund ist tutorien drei rektor
das zu deutsche redaktionsleiterin beim
german german marshall fund of the
united states
das ist eine stiftung die sich die
pflege der deutsch amerikanischen
freundschaft zur aufgabe gemacht hat
zugeschaltet aus frankfurt ist der
leiter des ard oder der ard
börsenredaktion markus könne und aus
washington die leiterin des dortigen
studio der deutschen welle
ines pohl frau pohl wann gibt donald
trump sichtbar und hörbar vor aller welt
auf was denken sie gar nicht also wir
haben glaube ich heute mit seiner
ankündigung zweieinhalb tausend
soldatinnen und soldaten abzuziehen aus
irak und aus afghanistan
einen kleinen vorgeschmack bekommen was
donald trump der präsident der
vereinigten staaten in den verbleibenden
neun wochen seiner amtszeit zu tun
gedenkt alles andere als eine friedliche
übergabe zu organisieren
er wird alles dafür tun seine macht für
die zeit nach dem weißen haus
vorzubereiten was wir haben
möglicherweise im schilde führt werden
wir auch noch besprechen frau lemke das
donald trump den sieg beiden es nicht
anerkennt ist das blindwütige es um sich
schlafen oder steht tatsächlich dahinter
ein eiskaltes kalkül als er hat das ja
schon sehr früh angekündigt dass er das
ergebnis der wahl nicht anerkennen wenn
jemand anderes als er selbst gewinnt und
ich halte das für ein sehr strategisches
kalkül wir hören ja jetzt dass er gerne
wieder kandidieren will 2024 also das
ist ein machtgebaren dass er bis zum
ende ausreizt
fotos freund wie groß ist eigentlich der
schaden für die amerikanischen
demokratie durch das was da gerade in
washington vor sich geht
man muss unterscheiden zwischen die
praktische und das wirkungs problem dass
praktischer wir haben das glück dass
biden und seine mannschaft die sind sehr
erfahren und die machen eigentlich diese
transition jetzt schon die werden halt
nicht bezahlt die kriegen kein bekommen
kein geld vom regierung die sind
beurlaubt von ihrer stellen aber die die
arbeiten schon dran und es wird das ist
problematisch aber die die werden das
schon hinbekommen aber was sehr schlimm
ist ist die wirkung also das ist eine
demokratische norm was und diese normen
sind sehr wichtig und die das ist jetzt
gebrochen ist dass diese wirkung bleibt
und das schadet eher eine politische
kapriolen mögen wirtschaft und börse ja
überhaupt nicht nur von schockwellen ist
weit und breit nichts zu spüren ist den
börsianern egal wer unter ihnen
us-präsident ist also mittlerweile schon
die unsicherheit an den märkten war im
vorfeld doch schon groß vor allen dingen
tatsächlich die sorge vor joe biden der
an vielen stellen schrauben bewegen
würde die den finanzmärkten nicht
gefallen könnten und auch der wirtschaft
abträglich werden das hat sich aber
gelegt mittlerweile haben sich die
börsen nahezu auf der ganzen welt
festgelegt und das schon seit einiger
zeit dass joe biden nicht nur neue
präsident sein wird sondern dass er auch
für die wirtschaft ein guter präsident
sein wird und nicht nur für die
vereinigten staaten sondern auch für den
rest der welt frau pohl glaubt
eigentlich noch irgendjemand in den usa
das zählmaschinen oder gerichte
gerichtsurteile donald trump noch zum
wahlsieger führen könnten
ja wir haben hier am vergangenen
wochenende am samstag
große demonstration von trump
unterstützerinnen und unterstützern
erlebt hier in washington 15.000 bis
20.000 menschen waren hier ich habe mit
vielen gesprochen den meisten haben
übrigens keine maske getragen ich habe
versucht sicherheitsabstand zu wahren
natürlich auch selbst hinter masken
ausgestattet und viele von denen
tatsächlich behaupten nach wie vor die
die wahl sei nicht verloren von donald
trumps sondern das sei wahlbetrug im
spiel
und manche sagen auch immer noch wenn
wir erst aus zellen dann wird sich
herausstellen dass donald trump der
eigentliche wahlgewinner sei aber die
zahl nimmt natürlich ab weil der
vorsprung doch jetzt so eindeutig ist
wir warten jetzt auf die ergebnisse in
georgia am donnerstag soll die
nachzählung bekanntgegeben werden das
kann noch ein bisschen knapp werden aber
es gibt noch versprengte anhänger die
glauben er kann es noch schaffen aber
die große große mehrheit auch der tramp
unterstützer und der republikaner
überhaupt hat doch ein einsehen dass die
wahl für donald schon verloren ist vor
allem diese hinhaltetaktik können wir
uns ja auch nennen die trump gegenüber
seinem nachfolger da zeigt dass nicht
anzuerkennen was offensichtlich ist hat
das vielleicht auch etwas mit der
stichwahl in georgia zu tun der hat ja
nichts mit der präsidentschaftswahl zu
tun von der ines pohl gerade gesprochen
hat von der auszeichnung sondern es sind
ja noch zwei senatssitze offen da gibt
es eine stichwahl zwischen demokraten
und republikanern in einem eigentlich
republikanisch dominierten bundesstaat
georgia
und wenn diese beiden sitze an die
demokraten fallen dann gäbe es sie ein
patt im senat mit der folge dass dann
die präsidentin des senats das ist ja
dann die zukünftige vizepräsident kamera
harris die stichstelle hätte und damit
eigentlich die blockadepolitik gegen
beiden obsolet wäre für die republikaner
ist das einer der gründe warum sich
donald trump so quer stellt warum er mit
dieser art seiner seines auftretens
vielleicht die leute bei laune halten
will dass die nicht resignieren in
george und zur wahl gehen ja also das
sind mit sicherheit einer der gründe in
georgia ist ja die war sehr knapp
ausgefallen für joe biden das erste mal
dass die demokraten dort in georgia die
mehrheit gewonnen
also auch bei der senatswahl wird es ein
sehr knappes rennen geben und es wird ja
dann noch mal wahlkampf geführt vor der
stichwahl und joe biden hat gesagt für
die demokraten gehe ich auch noch einmal
in den ring und unterstütze die beiden
kandidaten aber donald trump möchte
natürlich gerne diesen republikanisch
beherrschten senat beibehalten um
einfluss auszuüben über den senat auf
die gesetzgebung in den nächsten vier
jahren das ist also eine ganz klar über
so kalkulierte überlegung aber ich denke
auch dass nicht anerkennen des
wahlergebnisses bei den unterstützern
von denen wir gerade gehört haben hat
auch eine ganz problematische wirkung
indem auch wenn jetzt georgia
entschieden ist
die trump unterstützer immer noch
glauben beiden ist nicht legitim
also eher unterhöhlt sozusagen damit
auch die legitimität der gesamten
präsidentschaft von joe biden und das
ist für eine demokratie eigentlich
verheerend wenn es 70 millionen menschen
gibt oder vielleicht nicht alle
unterstützer die denken beiden ist
unrechtmäßig präsident der usa das ist
eigentlich verheerend dort ist ja
inzwischen allein zu haus kann man sagen
aber was hat er eigentlich noch vor bis
zum 20 januar außer golf spielen wieder
etwas im schilde womit er den
amerikanern für alle zeiten in
erinnerung bleiben möchte was meinen sie
ich glaube das muss man befürchten ja
also er hat ja neulich gesagt er würde
die truppen aus afghanistan somalia und
anderswo zurücknehmen man kann
wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen dass er
überraschende begnadigungen vornimmt das
machen ja die meisten präsidenten vor
die aus amtlich das bleibt noch spannend
also ab dem moment vor allem wo er
vielleicht anerkennen muss dass es
verloren ist
ich glaube wir könnten auf große
überraschungen zu stoßen
markus gürne diese überraschungen von
den 4000 freund der gerade spricht dann
gesagt die börsianer haben mit joe biden
als neuen präsidenten schon ihren
frieden gemacht aber diese
überraschungen dieses unberechenbar
dieses möglicherweise haken schlagen wir
kommen auch gleich noch auf ein paar
beispiele was da möglicherweise
passieren könnte könnte das wiederum
auswirkungen zunächst auf die börse aber
dann vielleicht auch auf die
us-wirtschaft haben die im moment ja
auch in einem sehr schlechten zustand
ist durch corona genau die
infektionszahlen den vereinigten staaten
die sind ja dramatisch da schlägt der
gesellschaftliche wandel die probleme
die es dort gibt sich natürlich auch auf
die wirtschaft nieder was die
finanzmärkte anbelangt so hofft man dass
es in jedem fall ja dieses große
angekündigte konjunkturprogramm gehen
wird das war in jedem fall klar dass
soll riesig sein 5,4 billionen in den
kommenden zehn jahren das sind also
viele möglichkeiten vorhanden
tatsächlich die wirtschaft da deutlich
zu stärken viele branchen da geht es ja
auch um die alten industriearbeitsplätze
die ja auch schon fremd den wählerinnen
und wählern versprochen hat dann die
will er auch joe biden tatsächlich
anknüpfen
aber die große frage die im raum steht
wird eigentlich die sein ob die
vereinigten staaten es schaffen werden
auch unter einer präsidentschaft von joe
biden mit china eine wie auch immer
geartete neue ära einzuleiten weil da
geht es ja schon um eine frage wer
wirtschaftspolitisch die große
hegemonialmacht auf der welt sein wird
im technologiebereich und das wird schon
noch interessant sein zu sehen mit
welchem tonfall wahrscheinlich
konzilianter aber wahrscheinlich auch er
genauso hart in der sache
die vereinigten staaten in zukunft
diesen kampf auch mit den chinesen
austragen werden und was der europäische
platz in dieser bei dieser periode dann
sein wird in bezug auf china haben ja
jetzt einigen den letzten tagen da schon
nägel mit köpfen gemacht da kommen wir
auch gleich noch drauf zurück auf diese
neue asiatisch-pazifische
freihandelszone zunächst mal ohne die
usa in das projekt ist ja heute
berichtet worden dass am letzten
donnerstag eine sitzung im oval office
war mit dem vize präsidenten mit dem
außenminister mike kompon und auch mit
dem generalstabschef und da soll donald
trump
fragt haben ob es denn möglich wäre
sozusagen zum ende seiner amtszeit noch
den iran anzugreifen ein
atomforschungszentrum wo offensichtlich
angereichertes uran lagert anzugreifen
das ist zwar im aus geredet worden von
diesen beratern aber wenn man sich das
mal ansieht ausgerechnet den iran
angreifen der sich ganz bestimmt massiv
während wird auf einem pulverfass sitzen
gemeinsam mit saudi arabien also eine
hochbrisante hochgefährliche gegen das
klingt eher wieder stich der bewusste
absichtliche stich in ein wespennest
was ist das wirklich ihm zuzutrauen dass
er eine solche ich sag's erstmal
kurzschlusshandlungen noch ausführen
könnte trump arbeitet wirklich
professoren linke hat es gerade schon
angerissen einer dolchstoßlegende er
versucht zu etablieren dass er die wahl
eigentlich gewonnen hat und er versucht
vorzubereiten
eine mögliche kandidatur in 20 24 die
übrigens erlaubt ist in den vereinigten
staaten so ein kleiner hintergrund
vielleicht ein mensch kann zwei
amtsperioden auszuführen anders als zum
beispiel in deutschland
aber die können durchaus unterbrochen
seien von der wahl der hat jetzt vier
jahre als er könnte durchaus noch mal
vier jahre im weißen haus regieren
und auch das ist schon mehrfach jetzt
angedeutet worden
die verbleibenden wochen sind meiner
meinung nach brandgefährlich wir haben
das heute erlebt mit dem angekündigten
abzug der truppen aus afghanistan und
dem irak auch das war weiß was er schon
immer wieder in aussicht gestellt hat
aussenminister pompeo reist jetzt nach
israel wird offizielle vertreter aus
bachrain treffen er wird sich mit
vertretern aus saudi arabien treffen
also genau die länder die diese fans
gegen den iran bilden
ich meine ich bin an sich sehr sehr
vorsichtig mit unken und zu sagen
ja es ist gut möglich dass donald trump
den iran angreift aber er ist wie ein
verletzter hund im eck und diese diese
ankündigung heute jetzt vor wenigen
stunden truppen abzuziehen
die macht uns hier in den vereinigten
staaten schon sehr sehr besorgt alle
experten die ich es gehört habe und
gesehen habe erhalten ganz ganz viel
tatsächlich für möglich in den
verbleibenden wochen
es gibt noch andere giftpfeile im köcher
von donald trump für die klimaschutz
oder umweltschutzbewegung er möchte
jetzt unbedingt noch vor der abgabe
seines amtes in einem nationalpark in
alaska erdöl fördern lassen ist das lust
an der zerstörung von verbrauchern oder
was was spielt damit ich meine da für
die ja auch in den letzten vier jahren
schon machen können und ein freund der
erdölindustrie war er schon immer
gewesen genau also er war immer schon
freund der erdölindustrie und auch der
kohle fossile energien
der kampf um die arktischen gewässer in
alaska der geht eigentlich jetzt seit
zehn fünfzehn jahren und immer wieder
sind pläne auf den tisch gelegt worden
dort zu bohren barack obama hat das
damals dann verhindert die einheimische
bevölkerung das ist sehr dünn
besiedeltes gebiet aber die einheimische
bevölkerung wehrt sich sehr stark und
ich denke schon das ist so ein versuch
vollendete tatsachen zu schaffen
es wäre für die beiden dann sehr schwer
das wieder zu revidieren also er
versucht soviel flecker einzuschlagen
wie möglich um es dann auch zu beiden
schwer zu machen in der klimapolitik
wirklich sowie beiden das ja vorsieht
konsequent umzustellen auf die
erneuerbaren energien und wegzugehen von
den fossilen also insofern ja also es
ist auch eine also ein steine in den weg
legen für die nächste generation könne
sie denn die us-wirtschaft dieses
ansinnen weg von erdöl weg von gaza so
von fossilen energien hin zu
erneuerbaren energien in den usa ist das
ja bisher eigentlich kein mehrheits
thema gewesen
da eine gefahr auch für die
wirtschaftskraft für den
für die stabilität der us-wirtschaft
also teile bestimmt aber es ist glaube
ich schon konsens nicht nur in europa
sondern auch in den vereinigten staaten
dass die zukunft dass vor allen dingen
die zukunft nicht nur was nachhaltigkeit
anbelangt sondern auch was die zukunft
seiner gesamten gesellschaft und des
wohlstandes in einer gesellschaft
anbelangt in innovationen liegt also der
frage in welcher hinsicht man in der
lage ist den neuen lebensbedingungen
tatsächlich und den möglichkeiten
rechnung zu tragen und man sieht ja ganz
eindeutig bei den unternehmen im silicon
valley wie erfolgreich die sind und dass
die technologieführerschaft einer
volkswirtschaft wie die vereinigten
staaten dass er sehr lange waren und in
teilen auch noch sind entscheidend dazu
beitragen werden wohin es mit einer
gesellschaft geht also ich glaube dass
es da nicht nur konsens gibt sondern
dass auch in der wirtschaft selber viele
verstanden haben dass sich mit ökologie
und ökonomie in der verbindung sehr viel
rendite machen lässt und das ist in
einem kapitalistischen system wie den
vereinigten staaten ja sehr wichtig
fotos sollen bevor es mit der wirtschaft
wieder auf die beine kommen kann
beziehungsweise bevor solche
entwicklungen angehen muss ein anderes
problem gelöst werden zu beiden hat
vergangene nacht in einer rede auch das
nochmal ganz klar benannt hauptthema
oder thema nummer eins ist die
bekämpfung der korona pandemie eine
eindämmung will tatsächlich hinkriegen
schutz der bevölkerung man will diesen
landesweiten lockdown vor dem sich alle
fürchten verhindern unbedingt verhindern
innerhalb von sechs tagen eine million
neue infizierte in den usa insgesamt
seit beginn der pandemie elf millionen
oder über 11 millionen die sich
infiziert haben könnte sein dass die
erste unfreiwillige amtshandlung von joe
biden ist diesem landesweiten locker und
tatsächlich einzuführen
das könnte sein das hat er noch offen
gelassen in seiner wirtschaftsrede er
hat gemeinde das mussten die
bundesstaaten entscheiden das sieht ja
auch unterschiedlich aus dem bundesstaat
zu bundesstaat allerdings in diese neue
zweite welle
das ist das betrifft deutlich mehr
bundesstaaten als die erste und andere
bunte städten also das heißt man bewegt
sich in eine richtung wo das
flächendeckend ist und auf jeden fall
geht er glaube ich davon aus dass kurven
bekämpfung seiner erste aufgabe sein
wird und zugleich wird damit die
wirtschaftliche schaden schon umgehen
müssen und vor allem wo ein hilfspaket
noch auf bleibt außen vor kritisierte
dass er mit seinem team hat er ein
eigenes team gegründet zur bekämpfung
der pandemie da gar nicht in die
washingtoner amtsstuben hinein kommen da
gibt es ja eigentlich ein gesetz das
diesen übergang regelt das wird einfach
nicht umgesetzt da wenn das jetzt alles
bis zum 20 januar dauern würde was hätte
das für konsequenzen gerade unter diesem
aspekt der usa dass die einen kroner
leugnen die anderen darunter leiten und
in der politik ein solcher streit
entsteht also alles wird dann dadurch
sehr ineffizient erstmal das ist
natürlich auch demokratie mäßig sehr
problematisch wenn noch 50 millionen
oder so davon ausgehen dass diese
amtsperiode legitim ist aber wenn wir
jetzt von q wie zum beispiel sprechen
es wird er kann dieser mannschaft bauen
er kann seine machen aber man kann dann
nicht überschneiden mit was schon
geplant ist vor allem wie dieser
impfstoff an die unterschiedliche
staaten bundesstaaten und so weiter
laufen soll das sind ganz konkrete
logistischer entscheidungen die man
jetzt nicht in einen tag treffen kann
und man auch nicht treffen kann ohne zu
wissen was schon vorher passiert ist
obwohl es gibt ja so eine art
silberstreif am horizont nicht nur den
usa sondern weltweit da ist
möglicherweise ein impfstoff unterwegs
der wirksam ist
man richtet sogar von 90 beim us-konzern
moderner sogar 94 prozent wirksamkeit
der soll jetzt schnell in großen dosen
hergestellt werden
aber offenbar sind sich die beiden teams
trump und beiden auch schon in die haare
geraten wer denn die impfstoff
verteilung in den usa organisiert wie
das ablaufen soll gibt es da etwas oder
können sie das etwas detaillierter
schildern was da eigentlich der
streitpunkt ist und wieder und welches
problem da auftaucht rachel
tausendfreund hat es ja schon ein
bisschen angerissen das große große
problem was soll also weiter mit seinem
wirklich hervorragenden team was er da
aufgestellt hat ist er kommt jetzt
einfach nicht an die informationen und
kann die dinge nicht so vorbereiten
wer ist eigentlich tun müsste damit er
dann am 21 januar wirklich loslegen kann
wir müssen uns immer vergegenwärtigen
dass in den vereinigten staaten wird ein
sehr sehr föderales system haben mit
ganz ganz starken staaten es ist
überhaupt nicht einfach für einen
präsidenten dadurch zu regieren
föderale gesetze zu erlassen bis hin zu
der verteilung von impfstoffen natürlich
sobald der impfstoff da ist ist ich habe
heute übrigens gehört dass moderner
schon 20 millionen stoff drohe in den
usa
wenn sich natürlich die zwei fragen wer
hat die möglichkeit den impfstoff zu
bekommen wenn man es möchte und wer wird
vielleicht das super pflichtet sich
impfen zu lassen vielleicht auch sogar
gegen den eigenen willen
da gibt es ganz widerstreitende
interessen natürlich darf es eigentlich
keine rolle spielen dass nur die
menschen in der lage sind sich impfen zu
lassen die das entsprechende geld haben
hier in den usa gibt es für viele
menschen keine vernünftige
gesundheitsvorsorge wie soll die dieser
impfstoff überhaupt erreichen das sind
alles wirklich riesige logistische aber
ich möchte fast sagen auch humanitäre
fragen die überhaupt nicht beantwortet
werden können solange diese übergabe
diese transition nicht stattfindet und
da ist nichts in sicht also frau linke
hat schon angesprochen die gute
nachricht ist dass joe biden selbst sehr
sehr erfahren ist und er auch sein team
mit ausgesprochen erfahrenen
politischen beamten würde mir sehr
wahrscheinlich in deutsch sagen
ausgestattet hat so dass wenn sie erst
mal im weißen haus sind können sie
loslegen aber bis dahin kann einfach
nichts vorbereitet werden könne im
frühjahr da war die us-wirtschaft ja
zunächst mal im freien fall dagegen
gingen die arbeitslosenzahlen durch die
decke also ganz nah sie viel massiver
als bei uns viel auffälliger gerade was
arbeitslosenzahlen angeht das hat sich
jetzt wieder etwas gebessert wenn es
tatsächlich zu diesem landesweiten
lockdown kommt was würde die usa das
vielleicht noch viel schlimmer erleben
was sie da schon im frühjahr
durchgemacht hat ja die vereinigten
staaten name im prinzip ja nur in einer
deutlich größeren dimensionen dasselbe
problem was wir in europa aussehen bloß
eben deutlich schlechtere
sicherungssysteme also da muss man sagen
dass schlägt diese gesellschaftsform des
liberalen kapitalismus dann deutlich den
regieren denn dann tatsächlich auch auf
die füße das ist ein großer unterschied
und das macht die us-wirtschaft auch
deutlich anfälliger auf der anderen
seite sind die vereinigten staaten aber
eben auch aufgrund ihrer
wirtschaftskraft und vor allen dingen
aufgrund ihrer eigenen währung in der
lage schuldenberge zwar anzuhäufen aber
sie dann auch deutlich leichter wieder
abzubauen wäre den dollar als währung
hat sagte schon der damalige
finanzminister ist dollar ist unsere
währung und euer problem der hat es mit
der weltleitwährung etwas einfacher
nichtsdestotrotz müssen auch die
vereinigten staaten irgendwann diese
schuldenberge abtragen und das wird eine
generationenaufgabe sein
und da ist es natürlich schon wichtig
dass eine gesellschaft nicht nur gut
miteinander funktioniert sondern auch
nicht so tief gespalten ist wie sie im
moment bei den vereinigten staaten eben
leider auch ist jahrzehntelang galt die
us gesellschaft die als sehr robust auch
sehr krisenfest
hat sich das geändert jetzt durch die
spaltung die markus gründe da
angesprochen hat die sich jetzt bei der
wahl auch gezeigt hat wie er mitten
durchs land geht also ich beobachte die
usa ja schon seit langer zeit und habe
auch schon in den 60er jahren späten
60er jahren eine sehr gespaltene
gesellschaft in den usa erlebt zur zeit
der bürgerrechtsbewegung also es ist
offenbar in zyklen immer wieder der fall
dass diese gesellschaft
droht auseinanderzubrechen und auch die
jetzige situation ist natürlich sehr
sehr kompliziert und auch sehr schwierig
weil die polarisierung ebenso viele
teile der gesellschaft umfasst und auch
die parteien nicht bereit sind
miteinander zu arbeiten vor allem die
republikanische partei hat sich immer
mehr von dem grundprinzip verabschiedet
dass er für die amerikanische demokratie
wichtig ist dass man zusammen arbeiten
muss um gesetze verabschieden zu können
und diese polarisierung ist tatsächlich
eine große bürde für die kommenden jahre
kann denn das joe biden möglicherweise
überbrücken hat ja angekündigt versucht
das ja diese polarisierung diese
spaltung zu überbrücken wird ihnen das
gelingen oder ist das eigentlich
unumkehrbar diese entwicklung dass sich
die gesellschaft so auseinander
entwickelt hat man hört ja auch immer
wieder demokraten verkehrende demokraten
republikaner nur mit republikaner die
haben überhaupt keinen persönlichen
kontakt mehr untereinander leben zu
sagen auf zwei unterschiedlichen
planeten und versuchen daraus ein land
zu machen ist das ist das eine
unumkehrbare entwicklung
ich glaube nicht also ich glaube schon
an die ihre bußzeit diese chaotische
demokratie die es eigentlich schon immer
war in den usa joe biden es ist ganz
klar in jeder rede ersetzt quasi alles
darauf zu versuchen eine einigung herbei
zu bringen zumindest ein bisschen und er
ist dafür auch der richtige mann würde
ich sagen das ist vielleicht nicht der
spannendste und keiner hoffnungsträger
in dem sinn aber der ist ein heiler also
ich glaube er macht er kann schon
fortschritte machten vor allem wenn er
wirtschaftspolitisch dieser rost welt
wähler anspricht und vielleicht auch in
new york und georgia auch seiner wähler
dort anspricht
also aber leicht wird es nicht sein aber
ich denke auch wie professor lembke
gesagt hat denkt an die sechziger
siebziger jahren das war auch eine sehr
gespaltene zeit und dann hat man sich
irgendwie wieder zusammenbauen
die heutige zeit also die medialen
landschaft ist eine andere und das ist
glaube ich das was ist sehr sehr
schwierig macht weil die die zwei teams
die lebenden eine andere fakten welt und
das war schon anders in den 60er 70er
jahren und das ist der große hürde und
das wird auch nicht leichter durch
sozialen medien die das alles noch
verschlimmern weil die leute wirklich
noch entfernte an irgendeiner gemeinsam
geteilte realität weil was ich zu sehen
bekommen ist was ganz anders als was sie
zu sehen bekommen und wir wissen es
nicht
und also das sind riesengroße probleme
aber mit eine mit politischer wille und
eine republikanische partei die
vielleicht anfängt zu sehen
systemstabilität ist auch in ihrem
interesse dass das kann man als angehen
also ist es nicht es ist nicht
hoffnungslos aber leicht wird es nicht
sein
ines pohl ist diese hypothek gerade was
die sozialen medien angeht
der vergleich den frau 1000 freunde
gerade gezogen hat bezog sich auf die
bürgerrechtsbewegung in den 60er jahren
und die nächsten ära in den 70er jahren
wo die usa auch gespalten waren aber
eben ohne die belastung die hypothek
sozialer medien ist dass das eigentliche
problem und lässt sich diese hypothek
überhaupt überwinden dass man eben dass
man in filter lassen wie man so schön
sagt in ihrer eigenen welt nebeneinander
her liegt ohne noch kontakt zu haben und
auch ohne noch die möglichkeit zu haben
miteinander zu kommunizieren
in den dialog zu kommen was ja die
voraussetzung einer intakten politischen
gesellschaft ist ein riesiges problem
ich finde als 3000 freunde ganz ganz
wichtigen punkt angesprochen
es ist ja nicht nur so dass die menschen
nicht mehr miteinander reden die
bachelor gesagt glaube ich auf
unterschiedlichen planeten
es ist fakt dass wissenschaft spielt in
diesem land nur noch bedingt eine rolle
weil weite teil dieses landes davon
überhaupt nichts mehr mit kriegen weite
teile beziehen ihre informationen aus
diesem internet wenn man dann fragt der
mensch wo habt ihr das denn gehört wenn
der wilde verschwörungstheorien
verbreitet werden wird ja im internet
das hat mich gelesen das stimmt und es
ist anders es findet 60er 70er jahren
gab es unterschiedliche medien und die
medien in den vereinigten staaten waren
schon immer politisch von anbeginn an
politisch orientiert aber es gab
trotzdem so einen gewissen grundkonsens
dass fakten eine rolle spielen also das
ist ein riesiges problem das andere
große problem welches ich sehe ist dass
es diesen amerikanischen traum diesen
american dream der ja sozusagen das
kernversprechen überhaupt dieses landes
war hinter dem sich dann doch alle immer
irgendwie wieder versammeln konnten dass
es dieses versprechen in dem sinne auch
nicht mehr gibt dass man denkt meinen
kindern wird es einmal besser gehen
also das sind für mich die beiden
existenziellen probleme die
gespaltenheit durch den sehr
unterschiedlichen medien konsum und das
nicht mehr wirklich vorhanden sein
dieses amerikanischen traumes der
irgendwie sowieso eine klebe masse diese
dieses unglaublich diverse land über so
viele jahrhunderte darf man ja sagen
zusammengehalten hat war kurz gerade da
wo fakten auf jeden fall noch eine rolle
spielen und weiterhin spielen werden
dass wirtschaft und handel der von trump
nicht nur angekündigte sondern auch
angezettelt angezettelt der handelskrieg
hat jetzt eine erste konsequenz die fast
sich in der oder ist gefasst in der
abkürzung rcp original comprehensive
partnership also eine regionale
umfassende wirtschaftliche partnerschaft
in asien unter führung der chinesen und
unter ausschluss der usa
da schon jetzt überall die alarmglocken
wie groß ist die gefahr für die us
wirtschaft auf der einen seite im
transpazifischen handel aber eben auch
für europa wir sind mit asien ja auch
eng verbunden gerade auch die
exportorientierte und exportabhängige
nation deutschland was geht da gerade
vor sich dieses freihandelsabkommen was
da in asien gezimmert wurde das muss man
ja tatsächlich sagen umfasst den größten
teil der menschen die auf diesem
planeten leben und dort ist der konsum
und die möglichkeit zu konsumieren wird
dort steigen das ist schon ein problem
das ist in doppelter hinsicht ein
problem es ist ein problem für die
vereinigten staaten die mit ihren
technologieunternehmen zwar viele
erfolgreiche produkte haben aber es gibt
nahezu in jedem bereich auch ein
chinesisches ponto und für uns in europa
wird es schwierig werden weil das was in
der tram pirat tatsächlich begonnen hat
glaube ich wird joe biden so einfach
auch nicht zurückdrehen können und
mutmaßlich auch nicht wollen weil am
ende wird sich die frage stellen
zwischen diesen beiden polen nämlich
einerseits china auf der anderen seite
die vereinigten staaten tatsächlich was
wird der platz europa sein und wir
können es sehen beim ausbau des
glasfasernetzes dass die chinesen gerne
ihren staatskonzern huawei in
deutschland an den start bringen wollen
die vereinigten staaten wollen das nicht
und dort wo man den
gucken und reizen der partner wieder
steht dort gibt es dann politischen
druck und das wird in der nächsten
näheren zukunft tatsächlich zu nehmen
und deshalb werden wir in europa uns gut
überlegen müssen was wir machen wir
können nicht nur auf asien setzen wir
können auf der einen seite auch nicht
nur wirtschaftlich auf die vereinigten
staaten setzen ich glaube die lösung für
uns europäer muss sein dass wir endlich
mehr über das reden müssen was uns
verbindet als ständig nur über das zu
reden was uns trennt auf diesem
kontinent
das heißt aber dass frau lemke diese
sowohl gegen die usa als auch gegen
europa wirtschaftlich gerichtete oder
gerichtetes bündnis national
comprehensive ökonomik partnership dass
das vielleicht einen positiven
nebeneffekt haben könnte nämlich das ist
europa und die usa wieder sozusagen in
ein boot zwängt weil man dann eben auch
gemeinsame interessen hat nicht nur
ökonomisch auch politisch auch die
sogenannte wertefrage dann vielleicht
auch wieder eine rolle spielt ist das
eine mögliche eine denkbare konsequenz
das ist eine sehr interessante these und
ich denke es gibt viele anhaltspunkte
dafür dass das so kommen wird das ist
ein weckruf für viele in europa dieses
bündnis das freihandelszone im pazifik
daran sind ja auch länder beteiligt wie
japan australien neuseeland also sind
eben nicht nur china und die kleinen
asiatischen länder sondern durchaus
große volkswirtschaften und für die
europäer ist das wirklich ein weckruf
vielleicht doch noch einmal nachzudenken
über ein neues tätig aber dann bitte
anders verhandeln
das ist ja leider auch nicht nur weil
die amerikaner ist nicht mehr wollten
sondern auch die europäer nicht mehr
wollten gescheitert und vielleicht kann
man indem man das transparenter
gestaltet indem man ökologische aspekte
einbezieht indem man eben auch
schutzmechanismen einbaut die stark sind
mit nordamerika also das wäre dann auch
neben den usa kanada so eine art neue
transatlantische zone entwickeln und
stark machen also ich denke da in die
zukunft müssen wir gehen
das geld wird der atlantik immer jetzt
als eigentlich als mehr der
vergangenheit die zukunft läge im
pazifik zwischen usa und asien ist das
vielleicht doch nicht so könnte es sein
dass das auch nicht stimmt was uns immer
wieder jetzt gesagt wir sollten nicht zu
viele hoffnungen in joe biden setzen
weil der wirt in vielen diese america
first politik weiterführen er ist auch
darauf angewiesen dass die wirtschaft
proben das ist nicht zu viele
arbeitslose gibt weil die firmen
auswandern in billiglohnländer
was kommt da jetzt auf europa zu diese
fielen europa haben ja gelitten unter
dieser missachtung der beziehung durch
donald trump ich glaube ich es kommt
einer partnerschaft wunsch erst mal auf
europa zu aber mit bringschuld dann also
das hat joe biden auch angedeutet montag
in seiner rede als er über china
gesprochen hat dass man dann erstmal
damit beginnen musste nicht die
alliierten ich glaube hat gesagt die
finger in die auge stecken während man
mit denen zusammen gegen china arbeiten
möchte also das wird ganz oben auf
seiner liste erst mal kommen bevor
glaube ich so was wie tippt tipp ist ein
einsamer verhandlungsstrategie wie man
china besser einbinden kann und so einer
fähre wirtschaftliche globale wirtschaft
die situation zusammen gestalten kann so
dass china mit machen muss und was ich
sagen würde dieser idee dass die beiden
auch america first ich finde das ist
eine falsche interpretation also es
stimmt schon dass joe biden auf jeden
fall auf amerika schauen muss da ist
sehr viel reparaturarbeit auch
wirtschaftlich volkswirtschaft nicht
leisten muss aber er wird er wird schon
eine kooperative amerika sein aber einer
der auch aufsicht gucken muss aber immer
ganz anders als der typische zeit
möglichst in partnerschaft und mit der
idee dass amerika mit gestalten muss
aber mitgestalten mit mehr hilfe
vielleicht als wir das in europa sehr
bequem finden werden
deutschland ist ja immer auch von den
usa geradezu kramp zeiten
rosinenpickerei vorgeworfen worden wir
würden viel dorthin verkaufen wenig
kaufen wir würden gleichzeitig aber
sozusagen kostenfrei den us schutzschild
den militärischen
da gerne akzeptieren wir seit 1945 ja
hier auch besteht jetzt hat ja die
bundesverteidigungsminister heute gesagt
ja das wird ja auch weiterhin so bleiben
dass wir auf die amerikaner angewiesen
sind das hat so ein bisschen geklungen
nach dem motto also ihr werdet weiterhin
für unsere sicherheit zuständig sein und
das müsst ihr euch auch etwas kosten
lassen wird sich da etwas ändern
ich glaube da wird sich was ändern
mussten also ich sah die rede von der
verteidigungsministerin jetzt die
neueste kommentar das war eine antwort
fand ich auf makro davor hatte sie ja
sehr starke transatlantische rede
gehalten wo sie gemeint hat wir werden
ein land der zusagen auf amerika
angewiesen ist wir sind die sicherheit
aber wir müssen auch selber viel mehr
leisten also mehr in diese partnerschaft
einbringen aber akzeptieren dass diese
partnerschaft bleibt und bleibt für uns
sehr wichtig ich finde das ist erdig
richtung die man gehen muss ich glaube
die auf dem man bereit sein muss in
berlin dass das deutschland was liefern
muss wenn es dieser partnerschaft stark
machen möchte jetzt bevor die usa andere
schützen können müssen sich auch erstmal
selbst schützen wenn man sich dieses
chaos dieser übergangszeit jetzt hier
anzieht gefährde das auch die nationale
sicherheit der usa russland und china
könnten ja versucht sein mal auf die
probe zu stellen wie weit sie da
eigentlich gehen können was sich die usa
in dieser situation dieser
schwächeperiode gerade so alles gefallen
lassen möglicherweise war der konflikt
um berg-karabach ja eine ein erstes
signal in diese richtung ist das auch
eine eine gefahr auch für die
internationale sicherheit im moment also
die befürchtungen gibt es durchaus also
vielleicht china weniger
china denkt wirklich in großen bögen und
glaube ich nicht in 90 tagen oder fünf
monaten sozusagen abschnitten aber
durchaus sie haben russland erwähnt
manche sagen wir wissen nicht was die
türkei im schilde führt chaos ist nie
gut für ein land dieser größe mit so
vielen feinden was donald trump hier
betreibt ich glaube das ist schon fair
zu sagen ist die eigenen also die
persönlichen interessen über alle
interessen dieses landes zu stellen und
damit natürlich auch ein gewisses risiko
einzugehen was ich sage jetzt mal
angriffe von außen anbelangt aber
natürlich auch durchaus unruhen und auch
gewaltsame ausschreitungen innerhalb der
vereinigten staaten ja marcus görner die
die politik von donald trump war ja sich
möglichst aus internationalen konflikten
zurückzuziehen das hat er ja vor allen
dingen auch im nahen osten ganz intensiv
betrieb mit dem hinweis wir sind jetzt
erstmal oder kümmern uns um unsere
interessen das waren auch in erster
linie wirtschaftliche interessen wenn
man jetzt diese vier jahre mal trump
vier jahre revue passieren lassen lässt
aus ökonomischer sicht hat sich das für
die usa gelohnt sich da auf die eigenen
interessen gerade auf die eigenen
wirtschaftsinteressen zu konzentrieren
es gab schon leute die profitiert haben
dass haben bloß leider glaube ich die
falschen profitiert also wenn sie sich
anschauen was sie in den vereinigten
staaten mit der steuerreform vorgefunden
haben dann sind die steuern für
unternehmen deutlich geringer geworden
da hat sich schon viel getan aber die
gesellschaft an sich hat nicht davon
profitiert da gab sehr viele
rückschritte und das ist der
volkswirtschaft vereinigte staaten über
die gesamte zeit tatsächlich nicht
zugute gekommen
die vereinigten staaten gehen aus der
ära trump für wirtschaftspolitische und
finanzpolitisch nicht gestärkt hervor
sondern wenn man sich jetzt die welt
anschaut dann muss man sagen ein
eindeutiger gewinner der letzten jahre
das ist china und china wird auch der
maßstab die benchmark seien für joe
biden in der frage wie bekommt man
wieder ein verhältnis hin das
amerikanisch
interessen tatsächlich vertritt aber in
der kommunikation eben nicht so auftritt
wie die administration von herrn trump
da wird sehr viel überzeugungsarbeit zu
leisten sein aber ich glaube auch dass
das tatsächlich eine chance ist wie das
hier auch gerade gesagt wurde dass man
die europäer und diese alte
transatlantische achse wiederbelebt und
zwar in einer anderen art und weise wie
wir es vor trump der fall war ich glaube
zurück zur vor trump ihrer wird so nicht
mehr möglich sein wenn man frau lemke
ein fazit dieser ära trump ein
vorläufiges sieht ist dass da ein ganz
giftiger cocktail den tramp da beiden
hinterlässt also er hinterlässt ihm ein
schweres erbe das ist gar keine frage
und was er gerne gerade angesprochen hat
also die kluft zwischen arm und reich
ist zum beispiel sehr viel größer
geworden in den usa in den letzten vier
jahren
und das wird auch für beiden sehr schwer
sein diese gruppen wieder
zusammenzuführen es gibt in den usa
viele studien die zeigen dass die mitte
also die mittelklasse in den usa immer
stärker geschrumpft ist und das hat
natürlich eine ganze reihe von sozialen
und auch von wirtschaftlichen folgen und
an dem punkt glaube ich ist das eine
sozioökonomische entwicklung die tram
mit befördert hat die aber glaube ich
auch in der wirtschaftsstruktur der usa
begründet liegen und da muss eigentlich
joe biden hauptsächlich anknüpfen sich
noch mal zu überlegen wie diese kluft
zwischen arm und reich in den usa besser
geschlossen werden kann
das heißt für die mittelklasse für die
breite mittelklasse eben auch eine
deutliche verbesserung der
lebenssituation eintritt diese kluft zu
schließen da haben sich schon viele
us-präsidenten unterschiedlicher
politischer prominenz versucht und sind
alle gescheitert ist dass in den usa
überhaupt möglich diese kluft zu
schließen da ja viele amerikaner ja von
diesen freiheitsbegriff auch gerade
leute die wenig geld haben die dann an
ihren amerikanischen traum glauben die
gar nicht bevormundet werden wollen die
ja sogar krankenversicherungen ablehnen
nur weil sie das als bevormundung
betrachten ist dass in den usa wirklich
bei dieser ideologie bei dieser
wirtschafts und sozial
logi überhaupt möglich diese kluft zu
schließen wenn jeder eigentlich nur auf
eigene rechnung und für sein eigenes
glück arbeitet das ist nicht einfach
weil man eine andere einstellung hat wie
sie gestaltet haben und man hat diese
föderale problem und sind sehr viele
unterschiedliche akteure die sehr viel
macht haben und die das leben sieht auch
sehr anders aus in casper wyoming oder
new york city das sind alles probleme
aber ich finde man kann ihn joe biden
wirtschaftsplan obwohl er noch ein
bisschen allgemein gerade ist sehr viel
noch von dieser linken senders wird
wollen politik sehen deutlich mehr als
sogar obama und auf jeden fall davor
also ich finde auf die mitte und minkel
mitte links spektrum in amerikanische
politik wird diese idee stärker dass man
anders was machen muss und das ist auch
zum teil geschuldet durch dieser
finanzkrise von 2008 2007 wo außer die
obersten 20 prozent
die leute haben sich nicht erholt und
ich glaube da haben einige eine lektion
gelernt dass man das jetzt grund legen
was ändern muss wenn nur die obersten 20
prozent sich erholt hat dann liegt was
falsch im system könnte ist es denkbar
dass ein us präsident eine linke
wirtschaftspolitik macht also ich glaube
es ist denkbar und sogar ganz wichtig
dass herr beiden eine sache anders macht
nämlich anders umverteilen hertrampf hat
umverteilt wie frau 1000 volks gerade
gesagt hat nach oben und herr beiden hat
er ein programm angekündigt das
umverteilen wird nach unten also die
steuern erhöhen für diejenigen die schon
sehr sehr viel geld haben oder das ist
in der situation der die vereinigten
staaten sind nicht nur wichtig sondern
eigentlich auch vollkommen unumstößlich
man muss das machen wenn man eine chance
haben will und ich glaube auch dieser
spaltung entgegen zu wirken aber auch
die vereinigten staaten wirtschaftlich
volkswirtschaftlich und darüber hinaus
dann am ende auch geopolitisch als
großer partner in der welt wieder auf
die bühne zurück zu holen
indes positives vorhin schon gesagt der
herr sei bei uns ist dass donald trump
2024 noch mal antritt jetzt hat er 73
millionen wähler auf seine seite gezogen
dass die zweithöchste zahl aller us
präsidentschaftskandidaten also
wählerstimmen die us
präsidentschaftskandidaten bekommen
haben übertroffen nur von joe biden mit
78 millionen kommt da die
republikanische partei überhaupt noch an
ihm vorbei für 2024
es ist eine ganz ganz gute frage die
republikanische partei sind nun ganz
großen problem sie haben diese über 70
millionen menschen die für trampe welt
haben nicht alle davon sind wirklich
massive trump unterstütze aber lasst uns
550 millionen sein
was machen was macht die republikanische
partei große frage ich habe da keine
antwort darauf wir sind wir versuchen
natürlich kontakt aufzunehmen mein
eindruck im moment ist das hat mir in
der runde ist auch schon diskutiert
die versuchen unbedingt die beiden
zumindest in einen senats platz in
georgia zu gewinnen das würde ihnen doch
innenpolitisch sehr sehr viel macht
einräumen dann könnte zum beispiel joe
biden auch keine nicht ohne weiteres
eigene supreme court justice ist
besetzen auch das ist immer wichtig wie
der oberste gerichtshof besetzt ist also
das warten sie jetzt glaube ich ab die
republikaner und dann müssen sie sich
neu sortieren
aber wenn donald trump wirklich nochmal
antreten will
2023 dann im wahlkampf 2023 wird es nach
aktuellem stand sehr sehr schwer sein
für die republikanische partei genau das
zu verhindern
eine ganz kurze antwort bitte ist trump
noch da selbst wenn er schon lange nicht
mehr da ist
er bleibt präsent wird sich ein
medienimperium aufbauen
das heißt also anstatt präsidentschaft
möglicherweise auch noch wirkungsvoller
als medienstar ich bedanke mich bei ines
pohl in washington vielen dank auch für
den kurzfristigen das kurzfristig
einspringen bei uns markus gürne aus
frankfurt christiane lemke und 80.000
freunde liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde organs veto platz das
corona hilfspaket müsste man ergänzen in
der europäischen union
jetzt folgt für nichts der tag mit
michael krons ein thema ist das haben
wir hier schon angesprochen die
grundsatzrede der
verteidigungsministerin zur bundeswehr
bleiben sports
[Musik]